human beings flourish
when they have power to direct the
course of their own life
the best way to have access to that
power is through participation in a
constitutional democracy
but democracy survives only if its
citizens
know how to participate
want to participate have the skills to
participate
constitutional democracy is a living
activity not something simply to learn
about on paper
this isn't an old-fashioned civics class
where you learn a bunch of information
about things that are distant from your
life
this is about putting yourself as a
learner in the position of an
active civic participant who needs to
know what you care about and how things
work
in order to shape your own civic journey
we'll still cover the traditional
disciplinary content think separation of
powers and checks and balances
you'll need to learn about rights and
responsibilities constitutionalism
the philosophical foundations of
democracy and the levers of change
but we will also ask you to put your
learning
into action you'll work from your
understanding of yourself
and your understanding of constitutional
democracy and the american political
community
to develop your own theory of change and
civic action project
healthy democracies depend on citizens
loving democracy and having the
knowledge and skills they need
to play their role as civic participants
you can't sit back in a constitutional
democracy
your civic actions are just beginning